one of the biggest problems with Smart
TVs these days is the remote you got
something like the Apple TV remote and
it's got just a couple buttons on there
it's pretty much completely useless and
then you've got some monster Google TV
remotes to have hundred thousand buttons
and for a keyboard and it's just way
overkill Phillips has a solution that's
kind of somewhere in between it combines
the convenience of using a smartphone
with the buttons you're used to on a
traditional rhythm it's called the you
want inside it's done to IR camera that
can detect its position in 3d space and
it's also vend accelerometers so going
to tech clicks and other gestures we
tried it out with some prototype
software here at Phillips and it works
pretty well it only took about two
minutes to get used to and as a really
precise control on screen I think it's a
really nice balance between what you
would get from the smartphone and one
hormones it comes in a couple different
models this one does not have a qwerty
keyboard but there is one that does it
can also come with voice control it's
not available for purchase for consumers
but third-party manufacturers can
license as